Kourtney Kardashian has a big bug  problem and they're multiplying or  infested with tarantulas or contain we  won't be able to sleep at night and I  just I will not feel comfortable until  these tarantulas are bullied on court  Kay's house is crawling with spiders on  the latest episode of Keeping Up with  the Kardashians this is insane while  soaking up the Sun in her backyard with  gal pal Larsa Pippen  the reality star flips out when she  discovers her pest control problem is  unresolved an exterminator already  sprayed her home twice Bolin I'm calling  the pest control guy this is in sane so  scared of it so big we had you guys  sprayed but there's a tarantula  currently there's one right now we're  looking season for those tarantulas  probably gonna take more sprays this  wild world was not for me I'm out of  here  [Music]